- [Instructor] The food cart has become
a popular business venture,
due to the low start-up cost,
due to the low start-up
and overhead costs.
So I read it the way it was
written with a comma here.
So I pause a little bit,
but that just felt strange.
It feels like I don't need that comma.
Let's read it without it.
The food cart has become
a popular business venture
due to the low start-up
and overhead costs.
Yeah, this is an unnecessary comma here.
No reason why I would need
a pause in my speaking
at that point, or in my
reading at that point.
So I wanna get rid of that comma.
So I'm definitely gonna change it.
And this is the only choice
that gets rid of that comma.
This one over here goes even stronger.
It puts a semicolon there,
which is really strange.
The food cart has become a
popular business venture,
semicolon, due to the low
start-up and overhead costs.
A semicolon should be separating
two independent clauses
if it's not being used to list things.
And you would only use it to list things
is if you're listing things
that had other punctuation,
especially commas, in it.
But here, due to the low
startup and overhead costs,
that's not an independent clause.
So definitely wouldn't
wanna use the semicolon.
And here, not only do they
keep the original comma,
they add another comma at the end.
So if I were to try to read it or write it
the way that this one describes it,
or the way this choice is I would say
the food cart has become
a, the food cart has become
a popular business venture,
due to the low startup,
and overhead costs.
So that's really, there's
no reason why I would wanna
put a pause there and there.
So rule that out.